last year white Americans accounted for
more than 37 000 suicides while black
Americans accounted for a little over 3
800 suicides now accounting for
population differences that means white
people are killing themselves at roughly
twice the rate of black people why are
so many media Outlets unwilling to talk
honestly and directly about the suicide
rate afflicting men in this country
whatever the reason they're not just
hiding data on suicide rates they also
rarely talk about all the other obvious
verifiable signs that men are suffering
in this country in ways they never have
before approximately 70 percent of
homeless people are men and the total
number of homeless people in this
country has more than doubled in the
last three decades meanwhile men are far
more likely than women to use and
overdose on virtually every illicit drug
that exists the number of these
overdoses has increased dramatically in
just the past 20 years you can see on
this chart here fewer than 20 000 people
overdosed in 1999 in 2021 that number
was over a hundred thousand